i am subhina haas i am a syrian gay
refugee activist
before the war it was not safe
at all for me to walk around
al-qaeda came into my hometown and they
said they will apply sharia law and
cleanse the city of all like sodomites
i expected to immigrate i did not expect
to run away
i am an advocate for lgbt and lgbt
refugees rights
when i went out from my country
i
found that the peace of mind and the
safety that i felt
i wanted everybody else to feel the same
i want them to feel like safe
syrian lgbt faced double discrimination
you escaped to save your life you
escaped your family rejection and then
to find your true self
it is
difficult to really live your life but
sometimes it's
healing
you start to realize how bad things were
and how good they will be in the future
the castro is a place where you
can
be whatever you want to be it may give
you this courage to come out to yourself
and
be who you want to be and the person
that you're supposed to be
i always thought that home is a location
but
home is where your friends are where
your love is
if home is not bad then i don't think
i'll find it anywhere else
you